nowhere to go  [Applause]  Beasley for three  Harris Beasley assigned step three  quantity  [Music]  [Applause]  on the one  Harris Beasley button for the lead  Denver leaves at 91  finally Anderson  [Music]  precisely  [Applause]  that's down leans in  Denver lead to 93 92 for the different  shot clock to game clock Anderson  [Applause]  three seconds  [Applause]  three seconds applying  the chosen Joker's tried to get it in  and throw it in they're going to review  it see whether he stepped out of bounds  Paul as he was out of bounds  [Applause]  tole looked like the tow I'm going to  heal the hill right there when he goes  down to shoot it  my seals do the heavy